So one classic study on display rules, we had students in Japan and in the U.S
being shown medical procedure films. And these were really disgusting films.
Arms being amputated, burn graphs and so on. Now, as it turns out they saw the
films in one of two different conditions though. Either alone or in the
presence of an authority figure. Now, in the US, it didn't matter whether the
students saw the film alone or in the presence of an authority figure, the
students showed real signs of disgust in either condition. But in Japan, it was
only when they saw the film alone did the students show the disgust face.
Because in Japan there's a rule, a cultural norm that prohibits disgust
expressions in the presence of an authority figure. So instead of that they
mask that disgust with a smile. Interestingly these smiles were not genuine
smiles because they didn't involve the eyes. So this is a good example of how
culture influences and dictates when it's okay to express which emotion. So
what about gender and emotion? Of course, the stereotype is that women are more
emotional than men. question is, is there any evidence for this stereotype?
Well, yes and no. So as it turns out, men and women express emotion very
similarly, although women do in fact smile a little bit more. But women do seem
to have an advantage in two areas. First, when talking about emotion, they're
more precise than that. Men seem to be a little bit more vague. And secondly,
women are better at reading emotion on people's faces and hearing it in their
voices.